I actually knew this story I knew who
Jesse Owens was before I saw this movie
because of Pawn Stars Thank You public
education for once again failing me and
having me learn about real history from
Pawn Stars race to race is the story of
Jesse Owens an insanely fast dude who
competed in the Olympics in 1936 yep the
Olympics in 1936
held in Berlin Germany he competes in
these Olympics to hopefully stake a big
[ __ ] you middle finger to Hitler who
could resist that now this movie starts
out with a leg up because the premise
itself is really interesting Jesse Owens
is like when you're out there on the
track those 10 seconds nothing matters
there's not black or white there's just
fast or slow you really feel like
whatever is on his shoulders when he's
out there on the track he is free I
really like that but dude that played
him did a really good job too I gotta
give it up for the acting in this movie
because they were solid he was good and
then Jason sudakis was good in the movie
I always like it when I see a comedic
actor step over to a more dramatic role
I just like that kind of expansion so
yeah that's good for you yeah spread
your wings a bit man don't get locked
into just doing funny bits he had a
charm to him a likeability you can
really see that Jesse Owens gravitates
to him he will I mean they're a team not
that Jesse Owens just needed hammers
they needed each other this movie does
lack a bit in town when you're watching
the movie it does have that
made-for-tv-movie vibe to it for sure
it's always a bummer when you see a
movie like this have that vibe but in
the end you're still entertained because
the story of Jesse Owens is just a damn
fascinating one however I was noticing I
mean this is there at the Olympics Jesse
Owens is competing this is it man the
gloves are off he's gonna race but the
events he races in our Sprint's and long
jump it's just the events are ten
seconds max let's Jesse Owens so it's
less than 10 seconds so it's not a lot
of time to build the tension when it's
going now there was one event that did a
pretty good job of it actually it's my
favorite scene in the movie it was just
a good show of sportsmanship and you
don't always see such good sportsmanship
in real life but you're just glad it
happened I just wish it happen more in
life but as fascinating as the life of
Jesse Owens is when you look at it it
just it is a paint-by-numbers biopic
paint-by-numbers biopic with kind of a
made-for-tv vibe to it but I can't say
the movie didn't have the fields and I
can't say I did not enjoy the movie I
enjoyed the movie I enjoyed the
performances I enjoyed the premise I
enjoyed the Olympic event I walked out
of race with a smile on my face and I
said to myself that movie is
good time no alcohol required right guys
so race have you seen it what did you
think about it and what's your favorite
Olympic movie of all time
bring on the Cool Runnings comments I
know it's happening whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more